- [Mark] All right. Ernesto.
Ernesto. Where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Yeah, I grew up in
South Central or South LA.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both your
parents when you were young?
- No, I don't know my dad,
my mom was a sole provider.
I was raised by my grandmother, basically.
And that was solely because my mother
had to always be at work.
She had to be at work for
like six in the morning.
So she would leave at
4:30 to get there on time
and then when she got home
it was usually after dark.
So my grandmother basically
saw me up to school
and received me when I came home.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- I was sheltered for
most of my childhood.
I was sheltered, so I was a naive.
Now, I would look out the window
see all the kids in the
neighborhood playing
and I'd ask my mom, "Can I go play?"
She'd tell me "No.", but
she never gave me a reason.
I was the only child then.
And my mother's only child.
So I don't know if that
had anything to do with it,
but I was sheltered.
She was over protective.
- [Mark] And you've been married before?
- No.
- [Mark] No kids?
- [Mark] So you'd like to go down to some
of the neighborhoods and
pick up some of the girls
that worked the streets.
- Yes.
- [Mark] How long has that been going on?
- Off and on, I'd say maybe 15 years.
20 closer to 20.
- [Mark] And you'll take
the girls to a hotel
or motel?
- Yes. Yes.
- [Mark] And you have regular girls
that you frequent or you change it up?
- Well as they say, variety
is the spice of life, so.
- [Mark] There's a lot to
choose from down there.
- Oh yeah.
That's why I couldn't understand.
One thing that I couldn't
understand when I was young
is you're supposed to marry one woman,
and still every woman has their
individual characteristics,
traits that are attractive.
So it's hard to pick just one.
- [Mark] Yeah. You do you go...
Which street do you
usually go to? - Figueroa.
- [Mark] Figueroa. Yeah.
Figueroa has a huge selection
of beautiful ladies.
(nods head)
There's something for everybody down there
and it's an interesting street 'cause like
after around 10, 11, like around midnight
you'll have cars lined up.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Like so many cars lined up.
- Like a drive through.
- [Mark ] Yes. It looks like
a drive through and the...
So many girls, so many guys looking,
I mean, I don't know how much,
how many of the girls are actually getting
picked up-
- Right.
- [Mark] but it's an
interesting phenomenon.
- True.
Some man just a drive around
just to see the women, I guess.
- [Mark] Just look at them.
- Just to look at them.
It's a turn on, I guess.
Everyone has their own
vice or what have you.
- [Mark] And what kind
of things have you seen?
You've had some crazy experiences?
- Yeah. I mean pretty much
everything from being robbed.
Well, yeah, robbed basically.
- [Mark] Yeah. Some of the
girls that's their specialties.
- Yeah. And I don't know how she did it.
Because maybe her feet or
something, I don't know.
But yeah, it was odd.
'Cause I had my money tucked in my shoe.
So when I take my shoes off,
but she never got off the bed.
So I don't understand how,
but hey.
- [Mark] The girls are pros.
- Yeah sure.
- [Mark] You ever been arrested for...?
- Yeah, I was arrested.
I've been arrested for
burglary.
- [Mark] But like not solicitation? - No.
- [Mark] Nothing related to this? - No.
That's possession. - [Mark] Yeah.
- No, but I'm just talking in terms of
the girls working the street.
You enjoy the freedom?
- Yeah definitely.
I try relationships and
it's too much of a headache,
too many expectations once it's official.
It's like, you have to do this,
you have to do that.
And I guess you could
say I have an affinity
for non-conformity.
I guess I don't like
to be told what to do.
- [Mark] Yeah. - I mean-
- [Mark] Are drugs are part of your life?
- Yeah. They were for awhile
and I take a step back
sometimes 'cause I go so far
and I mess up so much money and I say,
"okay, you got to get it together",
but then I'd stay clean.
I've been through drug programs.
Outpatient, inpatient, the whole deal.
I mean obviously there
was a underlying issues
that they say
we take the drug.
The drug is not the issue,
We take the drugs to resolve our issue.
Whatever it may be.
Whether it be forget
about it or cope with it
and deal with it.
I think my main thing was
I didn't know my father
and I just couldn't understand how you...
Regardless of what the
situation or circumstance was
between you and my mother and
it has nothing to do with me.
I'm your seed how could you not look for
your seed.
So I don't know. I think that
probably played a big role
in me making some of my life choices.
And like I said, my
mother was an only child,
I don't have any aunts, uncles, cousins.
I didn't have any
positive male role models
per se growing up.
So yeah, once I got a taste
of freedom, it broke wide.
So being out in the streets,
what's out in the streets,
pimps, players, hustlers, thugs.
So those were like my male role models,
I guess you could say.
- [Mark] So I mean you're...
Because of the childhood
experiences you had
the commitment of a marriage
or something like that
might not be your forte.
- I mean I would like to be married.
'Cause that's the ideal thing.
Have a family and buy a
home and so forth and so on.
I mean I would like to settle down.
As part of the reason why
I don't have any children,
everyone has their issues.
No, one's perfect.
Including myself, of course.
And I don't think I've found anyone
to where even if we have our differences
she won't play pawn with my kids.
You know, you can't see your son
because you want to have sex with me.
You can't see your daughter
because you won't give me money.
Because that's important to me.
Because my father wasn't there for me.
So like the relationships I've been in,
they usually already have children.
So I try to be a constant in their life.
I tell them I'm not your father,
but you can still lean on
me, whatever it is you need.
An interesting part is
that I still keep in touch
with most of my exes children.
I call them and wish them happy birthday
and they really appreciate it.
They say, "wow my own
father doesn't call me
on my birthday."
And so that hits home
with me as far as kids,
children, whatever.
So yeah, I mean I hope to be married.
- [Mark] Did you ever find yourself
developing stronger feelings
for any of the girls
that you pick up?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I'm genuinely a caring person.
I try to befriend them,
I guess you could say.
So it's not so much like
a business transaction.
I think I'm just generally
concerned for people in general.
So I try to get to know
them and see what led them
to pretty much like what they're doing.
What led them to become a prostitute
and nine times out of
10, the constant variable
in their stories is that
they were abused at home
at a very early age by
whether it be a parent,
whether it be a relative or a neighbor
or whatever the case may be.
- [Mark] It's pretty much
like a hundred percent
of the time?
- Yeah. Pretty much.
I mean, I've learned that over the years.
Either they were abused or
abandoned, one of the two.
So they were in foster care, foster system
and nine times out of 10
you're gonna get abused
in the foster system.
Whether it be physical
abuse, sexual abuse.
It all plays a part especially
when you're at a young age,
it affects you.
And if you don't get a
treatment for it, therapy,
it stays with you.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I've interviewed a few hundred, I think
of these girls and it's
like sometimes your heart
just opens up and you wanna save them.
You wanna help them.
You wanna do something for them.
And I don't know that.
I don't know that it's
even possible sometimes.
- Yeah. I mean I try to be an optimist.
Some of the stories that I've
heard from some of the women,
it's like it makes me feel like
I haven't gone through anything.
When they tell me their stories it's like,
"Wow, you really survived
that and you're still here
and you're still-
- They've been through a lot.
- Yeah. They've been through a lot.
I was like...
- [Mark] I think I'll be eternally hopeful
that someday I'll save
somebody or help somebody
in some way that makes a real difference
but they seem to be
resistant to it as well.
It's almost like they're so
ingrained in this low self-worth
that this career requires.
- True. I think once you...
Once you've been through so much,
it's like one thing after another.
It's like you expect that's
what you've come to expect.
So why even try to pick myself up
when something negative
is gonna happen anyway
every time I do.
Which has been my life story as well.
Like when I tried to
run away from the drugs
and street life is like,
I'll take, I'll get a job,
I'll take two steps forward.
And then something in life, a life hurdle,
I guess you would call
it, will make me stumble
and I'll fall back two steps.
I'll take one step forward
and two steps back.
As they say, you'll make progress in time.
So it's like...
Well what's the sense
of continuing to try.
And it's like...
And they say your life is predestined.
You know I don't know how true that is.
I think it has to do with
a lot of your choices,
within your choices come
from how you were raised
where you were raised.
Your environment is
part of who you become.
- [Mark] Yeah. What I suspect is the abuse
that we experienced as
children are like...
Let's take some of the girls
that work at the streets,
the abuse, the lack of
love, the disrespect
that they endured as
children become something
that they look for as adults.
- They say it has a standard.
Because that's an interesting point
because I noticed when I try
to help, I guess you could say
to whatever extent, it's
like they push you away.
If you're nice to them they pushed,
they don't want that.
They don't know how to react to that
because no one's ever been.
And so it's like...
I'm like "What's wrong?"
But I had to come to the realization that,
once you've been through so much
and then they've probably been tricked,
someone came to them and
in that fashion as an...
As if they were wanting to help them
and then it wound up being
something completely opposite.
- [Mark] Well, I think that
the only thing that works
for an adult who's been abused as a child
is something very similar
to that relationship
that they were abused
in when they were young.
So this working the streets
and being treated like
just being used by everyone
does the trick nicely for them.
That's my suspicion.
Because they say they might
want a Prince charming
to come and save them.
But when he does, when he shows up,
they don't know what to do with it.
- Well I think it comes
along with the territory
because when you live in the street
or whether you live in the street
or you have an apartment or whatever
you have to be aware of everyone.
So you can't be nice to anyone.
- [Mark] You can't trust anybody.
- You can't trust anyone, you can't.
I mean that's to be expected.
I have some friends that I grew up with,
I saw them prostituting one day.
I tried to talk to her and I was like,
"Well, what's the issue?"
She was like, "There is
no issue. I enjoy sex.
And when I was doing
boyfriends and so forth,
I was having sex, but I was still...
I still had needs.
I still had
bills.
And so someone told me,
'Well if you're gonna flip
you might as well get
paid, why fuck for free?'."
I mean it's the oldest profession.
I don't know if that has
anything to do with it, but yeah.
So they took that upon as their motto.
- [Mark] Yeah. It's an interesting
subculture here. - True.
- [Mark] Well, Ernesto,
thank you for coming in
and talking with me.
- Thank you for having me, Mark.
- [Mark] Be careful.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] Don't get robbed again.
- Yeah. I learned my lesson from that.
- [Mark] All right. Thank you very much.
- Thank you.